[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
willkommen Fußball gibt es von Norbert
Lehmann ganz von mir und wir schauen
unter anderem auf die Ukraine und den
Besuch der EU-Kommission
noch mehr Hilfe für die Ukraine in Kiew
kündigte EU weitere 500 Millionen Euro
und neue Sanktionen gegen Russland an
Erinnerung an Stalingrad 80 Jahre nach
dem Sieg über die deutsche Wehrmacht
nutzt Präsident Putin die Gedenkfeier
für seine Propaganda
und Schlag gegen
geldautomatensprengermittler lassen eine
Bande auffliegen die mehr als 5
Millionen Euro erbeutet haben soll
das hat es noch nie gegeben fast die
gesamte EU-Kommission zu Besuch in einem
Kriegsgebiet für zwei Tage ist die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin mit 15
Kommissarinnen und Kommissaren in der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt morgen findet
dort ein eu-ukraine-gipfel statt und
auch heute ging es neben weiterer Hilfe
auch um eine EU-Beitritt der Ukraine
Florian neuhahn berichtet
sie kennt diesen Weg diese Stadt diesen
Präsidenten mittlerweile so gut wie kaum
jemand aus dem Westen Kiew am Mittag für
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen ist es der vierte Besuch seit
Beginn des Krieges und der erste zu dem
sie an den Großteil ihrer EU-Kommission
mitgebracht hat es wirkt bei einer wie
ein Klassenausflug mehr Symbol geht kaum
der ukrainische Präsident selenski weiß
all das zu schätzen auch wenn Symbole
allein ihm wohl zu wenig sind
um gegen den Feind zu gewinnen reichen
Sieger auf dem Schlachtfeld nicht aus
wir brauchen auch den Glauben an einen
friedliches und vereintes Europa und wir
brauchen die Stärke unserer
Institutionen
kurz vor dem Besuch aus Brüssel wird
gestern die Wohnung eines Oligarchen
durchsucht hier will zeigen dass es
ernst macht den Kampf gegen Korruption
und drängt heute auf einen schnellen
Beitritt in die EU von der Leyen kann
ihm wenig versprechen über jeden
weiteren Schritt müssen Europas
Mitgliedstaaten entscheiden und so
bleibt sie unbestimmt aber ermutigend
dein Durchhaltevermögen und die
Entschlossenheit der EU beizutreten sind
beeindruckend die Bewerbung für den
EU-Beitritt habt ihr brillant
vorbereitet
brillant ein paar Zusagen haben die
Besucher auch noch im Gepäck weitere 150
Millionen Euro für den Wiederaufbau der
Energieinfrastruktur
2400 Stromgeneratoren und die Aussicht
auf einen zehntes Sanktionspaket gegen
Russland in drei Wochen all das aber
verblasst gegen die großen Symbole des
heutigen Tages
und vor Ort in Kiew ist für uns Katrin
Eigendorf Katrin wie treten die Ukraine
auf gegenüber der EU
ja mit großer Dankbarkeit aber es ist
ganz klar sie sehen sich hier nicht als
Bittsteller sondern im Prinzip ist die
Geste das für die EU so sagen die
Ukraine und das macht selenski auch
immer wieder klar die Ukraine und ihr
Beitritt eine Bereicherung ist denn das
machen die Ukrainer selbstbewusst immer
wieder deutlich es gibt kaum ein Volk in
Europa das mehr dafür getan hat und mehr
dafür gekämpft hat diese Perspektive in
Europa zu bekommen für das die Werte wie
Rechtssicherheit
Wohlstand ja Demokratie mehr zählen als
für die Ukraine und deswegen tritt man
hier das zeigen ja auch die Bilder
durchaus auf Augenhöhe den Kommissarin
und auch Frau von der Leyen entgegen das
ist das Bild dass man hier in Kiel
vermitteln will und man muss ja auch
sagen das war das was die Ukraine hier
erreicht haben eigentlich im Prinzip
schon relativ viel ist wenn man sieht
das ist ein Land im Krieg das sehr stark
mit Korruption zu kämpfen hat dass er
noch bei weitem nicht dabei ist die
Kriterien zu erfüllen die gefragt sind
hat man doch hier sehr viel erreicht
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung Katrin
Eigendorf
bei einem Raketenangriff auf grammatosk
im Osten der Ukraine sind mindestens
drei Menschen getötet und 20 weitere
verletzt worden die Behörden fürchten
dass sich noch mehr Opfer unter den
Trümmern befinden könnten nach Angaben
der ukrainischen Polizei schlug die
Rakete gestern am späten Abend in ein
Wohnhaus ein sieben angrenzende Gebäude
wurden teils schwer beschädigt
mitten im Krieg gegen die Ukraine feiert
Russland den Sieg der Sowjet Armee über
die Truppen Nazideutschlands die
Schlacht um Stalingrad der Wendepunkt im
Zweiten Weltkrieg heute vor 80 Jahren
endeten die grauenvollen Kämpfe
hunderttausende Soldaten und
Zivilistinnen und Zivilisten starben am
zweiten februar 1943 ergaben sich die
letzten deutschen Soldaten der Jahrestag
heute wird opulent gefeiert und
Präsident Putin nutzt ihn für die eigene
Propaganda Christian sem berichtet
Stalingrad statt Wolgograd steht auf den
vorübergehenden Ortsschildern am
Stadtrand in Wolgograd lehnt die
Mehrheit der Menschen eine dauerhafte
Umbenennung zurück in Stalingrad ab
das ist kompliziert und teuer und die
ganze Welt kennt uns als Wolgograd das
wichtigste ist der Platz im Gedächtnis
der Menschen im Gedächtnis von uns allen
zwei Tage lang wird an die brutale
Schlacht vor 80 Jahren erinnert und den
Sieg der Roten Armee über die Nazis bei
den Kämpfen in Stalingrad starben
Hunderttausende auf beiden Seiten bis
heute finden hier noch Beisetzungen
statt dennoch immer werden sterbliche
Überreste von damals gefunden und
während die Menschen hier trauern jetzt
sich bald der russische Angriff auf die
Ukraine
es ist sehr traurig dass wir jetzt
gegeneinander kämpfen das liegt an den
Politikern an politischen Gruppierungen
in der Ukraine die Russland in jeder
Weise aus der Geschichte streichen
wollen
genau dieses narrativ wird von der
russischen Propaganda immer wiederholt
und das Russland in der Ukraine wieder
gegen Nazis Kämpfe die Menschen hier
haben nicht vergessen dass damals
Ukraine und Russen gemeinsam gegen die
Nazis gekämpft haben und trotzdem müsse
Russland heute die Ukraine besiegen
erzählen uns die Menschen hier am Abend
hielt dann Präsident Putin seine
erwartete Rede in wolgograf er warf
Deutschland vor sich in den Krieg
reinziehen zu lassen
unglaublich aber wahr wir werden wieder
von deutschen Leopard-Panzern bedroht
die an Bord Kreuze haben und wieder
gegen Russland auf dem Boden der Ukraine
kämpfen
russland werde sich zu verteidigen
wissen sagt Putin in den Augen seiner
Kritiker missbraucht er damit heute
wieder einmal einen wichtigen Gedenktag
für seine Propaganda
der Gedenktag in Wolgograd und der Krieg
in der Ukraine gleich um halb acht Thema
in ZDF heute live zu sehen da heute App
und den Social Media Kanälen mit dabei
auch Katrin Eigendorf von Kiew und
Christian Semm in wolgograf
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner aber heute
bei der Bundeswehr in Mali mehr als 1100
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind derzeit in
dem westafrikanischen Land im Einsatz im
Rahmen der UN blauhelmission minusma im
Raum steht die Bundeswehr noch früher
als geplant abzuziehen wegen der
militärunter aus Mali berichtet Andrea
Maurer
Camp Castor im Nordosten von Mali es ist
der größte und gefährlichste
Auslandseinsatz für die Bundeswehr bis
früher 2024 soll er noch dauern der
Finanzminister und FDP-Chef kommt zu
einer Zeit in der über einen früheren
Abzug diskutiert wird die
Bundesregierung hat klar gesagt dass wir
den mali-einsatz beenden werden das wird
aber kontrolliert ablaufen wir wollen
den Übergang zu einer verfassungsmäßigen
Ordnung begleiten eingeordnete Abzug
würde 50 Wochen dauern im Sommer soll er
stand jetzt beginnen die Franzosen sind
schon raus die Briten Niederländer und
Schweden ziehen dieses früher ab etwa
800 russische Wagner sollten er kämpfen
nun für die malische Übergangsregierung
gegen die Dschihadisten für die
Bundeswehr wird die Lage immer riskanter
seit Monaten verweigert mal die
drohnenflüge zur Aufklärung und eigenen
Sicherung
also die Drohnen können mir tatsächlich
nicht mehr einsetzen seit dem 23
Dezember da haben wir sie letztmalig
eingesetzt das ist natürlich ein Kern
des Geschäfts was ich hier betreiben
soll mit meiner
Truppe hier im Mai will der Bundestag
über eine letzte Mandatsverlängerung um
ein Jahr entscheiden voraussetzung dafür
war immer dass die Sicherheit der
eigenen Soldaten gewährleistet ist bei
den Soldatinnen und Soldaten hier
spielen wir gerade viel Unsicherheit
worauf können Sie sich einstellen und
vor allem in welcher Lage lassen Sie das
Land zurück in dem die Bundeswehr seit
2013 engagiert ist in der Hauptstadt
bamaco trifft der Finanzminister ohne
Kameras an diesem Tag auch den außen und
den Finanzminister es geht um
wirtschaftliche Perspektiven und die
überflugsrechte wie viel Einfluss
Deutschland hier noch hat ist fraglich
längst versuchen die Russen das macht
Vakuum zu füllen
durchgesickert war es ja schon jetzt hat
bundesinnenministerin Feser für Klarheit
gesorgt sie tritt als Spitzenkandidatin
der SPD für die hessische Landtagswahl
im Oktober an sollte sie nicht
Ministerpräsidentin werden wolle sie
innenministerinnen in Berlin bleiben sie
äußerte sich auch zur doppelten Rolle
als Ministerin und Wahlkämpferin das ist
eine demokratische
Selbstverständlichkeit aus dem Amt
heraus zu kandidieren und das mache ich
ebenso wie Herr Scholz ist damals als
Finanzminister gemacht hat Frau Merkel
aus dem Amt der Bundeskanzlerin heraus
oder Herr Laschet der damals
Ministerpräsident war und im übrigen
wird es auch mein mit Konkurrent der
hessische Ministerpräsident zu tun
morgen soll Fräser offiziell nominiert
werden
wer einkauft oder tankt merkt die Preise
können meist nur eine Richtung und zwar
nach oben auch der Europäischen
Zentralbank macht die weiterhin hohe
Inflation sorgen
nach einer langen nullzinsphase hat sie
den Leitzins seit Juli vergangenen
Jahres schrittweise erhöht heute
verkündete die EZB einen weiteren
Anstieg um 0,5 Punkte auf jetzt
3%, den höchsten Stand seit 2008 welche
Konsequenzen das hat Markus Wölfer
der Traum von den eigenen vier Wänden
für viele rückt der derzeit in weite
Ferne der Grund teure Materialien aber
vor allem steigende Kreditzinsen
baufinanzierungsberaterin Bianca Löffler
muss seit dem vergangenen Jahr viele
schwierige Gespräche führen der sich
Anfang des Jahres 300 000 € leisten
konnte dann auf einmal nur noch 200
250.000 € finanzieren was mit dem
Baupreisen aktuell natürlich kollidiert
und die Bau und Kreditzinsen werden wohl
noch weiter steigen die Europäische
Zentralbank hat heute den leitzin zum
0,5% Punkte auf nun 3% erhöht es ist der
fünfte Zinsschritt in Folge im Kampf
gegen die weitere Inflation
Kipping Inter straights at restriction
ein höheres Zinsniveau wird im Laufe der
Zeit die Inflation senken indem es die
Nachfrage dämpft und gleichzeitig dem
Risiko vorbeugen dass sich die
Inflationserwartungen dauerhaft nach
oben verschieben
ein höherer Leitzins macht sparen für
Verbraucher wiederum attraktiver
teilweise gibt es wieder zwei Prozent
Zinsen aufs Tagesgeldkonto gleichzeitig
werden aber die Investitionen teurer
viele Firmen waren deshalb die
angeschlagene Wirtschaft nicht zu
überfordern für viele Experten ist der
Zinsschritt dennoch überfällig wenn die
Europäische Zentralbank falsche
Rücksicht hier neben würde auf die
Konjunktur dann würde sich die Inflation
nur noch weiter festsetzen im System und
dann bräuchte man später noch mehr
Zinserhöhung die der Konjunktur noch
mehr schaden würden für die nächste
Sitzung im März hat die EZB bereits die
nächste Zinserhöhung in Aussicht
gestellt
die Geldpolitik der EZB ist auch für das
Geschäft der Banken wichtig die Deutsche
Bank hat im vergangenen Jahr so viel
Gewinn gemacht wie seit 15 Jahren nicht
mehr nämlich 5,6 Milliarden Euro pro
steuern das ist ein Plus von 65% im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr von einer
erfolgreichen Neuausrichtung
sprachkonzern-chef sebing die Deutsche
Bank hatte in den vergangenen Jahren
tausende Jobs gestrichen und sich wieder
mehr auf privatkundinnen und Kunden in
Europa konzentriert
fast 500 Geldautomaten wurden im
vergangenen Jahr in Deutschland
gesprengt es geht blitzschnell passiert
meist in der Nacht die Täter gehen
skrupellos vor zurück bleiben oft
verwüstete Gebäude schockierte
Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner jetzt eine
Ermittlungserfolg in den Niederlanden
wurden Mitglieder einer Bande
festgenommen die vor allem in
Süddeutschland aktiv war aus München
Julian Schmidt
[Musik]
sechs Szenen die sich so im Schnitt
mindestens einmal pro Nacht in
Deutschland abspielen vermummte dringen
eine Bank ein sprengen den Geldautomaten
und fliehen Überfall auf die
Raiffeisenbank in Worringen bundesweit
häufen sich solche Fälle diesen Tätern
gelang zunächst die Flucht doch am
Montag haben Ermittler aus Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg 9 Verdächtige in den
Niederlanden und Belgien gefasst
wir haben viele Behördenstrukturen
eingebunden auch die europäischen
Agenturen und deshalb ist dieser Fall
ein Musterbeispiel für eine gut
funktionierende grenzüberschreitende
Bekämpfung von organisierter
Kriminalität die Festgenommenen sind
zwischen 25 und 41 Jahre alt nach drei
weiteren Verdächtigen wird derzeit
gefahrendet alle leben in den
Niederlanden und Belgien die Ermittler
glauben die Täter weichen auf
Deutschland aus weil die Banken in den
Niederlanden ihre Sicherheit erhöht
haben viele operieren nun in Deutschland
kundschaften zunächst geeignete Banken
aus nach dem Überfall flüchten sie über
die Autobahn ins Ausland und gefährden
dabei andere
und letzten Endes gab es natürlich auch
Überwachungsbilder von Autobahnen wo die
Täter die ja mit
hochgeschwindigkeitsfahrzeugen unterwegs
waren gelegentlich auch geblitzt
fotografiert worden sind ihre Beute rund
5 Millionen Euro doch die Täter
hinterlassen Sachschäden in Höhe von
mehr als 6,7 Millionen Euro und viele
zerstörte Banken
alle macht den Nanas das war die Parole
von Niki de saint-fall als sie Mitte der
60er Jahre ihre berühmteste Werkserie
schuf die Nanas als Symbol der Befreiung
gegen das Patriarchat
2002 starb die französische
amerikanische Malerin und Bildhauerin
sie gilt bis heute als eine der
europäischen pop-art-künstlerin die
schon KUNSTHALLE FRANKFURT zeigt ab
morgen und 100 ihrer vielfältigen
Arbeiten in den Klinge mit einem Blick
auf die Ausstellung
Niki de Saul schießt auf Gips Reliefs
mit Farbbeuteln gefüllt ihre Wut richtet
sich Anfang der 1960er Jahre gegen die
Konventionen und Machtverhältnisse der
Zeit sie zielt auf ihren Vater der sie
als Kind missbrauchte auf Männer
insgesamt und Politiker in der Phase des
Kalten Krieges
der Zerfall ist eigentlich eine
skandalöse Künstlerin sie hat es
geschafft den Feminismus auf die
Plattform der zeitgenössischen Kunst zu
hieven sie hat ein Gewehr genommen um
auf Bilder zu schießen sie hat das
Publikum eingebunden in ihrer Arbeit und
sie hat es geschafft damit die
Kunstgeschichte aus der Perspektive der
Frau zu revolutionieren die Ausstellung
in Frankfurt hat das gesamte Werk der
französisch-amerikanischen Künstlerin im
Blick von frühen Gemälden bis zu ihrem
großen Skulpturen den berühmten Nanas
die Position der Frau beschäftigt Nici
de saarfall ihr Leben lang sie zeigt sie
als Mutter Braut und Ehefrau in
Rollenbildern gefangen und altern
Enkelin blumenkadenas ist stolz auf ihre
Großmutter
es war großartig sie als Beispiel zu
haben dass alles möglich ist wenn du die
Vorstellungskraft hast und wenn du stur
genug bist für das zu kämpfen woran du
glaubst dann kann es wahr werden
die prallbunten Nanas sind Niki de San
falls Befreiungsschlag und eine Art
Liebeserklärung an die Weiblichkeit
selbstbewusst und stark
Schneemangel das war Anfang des Jahres
ein großes Thema im Süden Deutschlands
aber das ist könnte man sagen Schnee von
gestern und ein halber Meter Neuschnee
in manchen Region sogar ein Meter soll
dort zusammenkommen bis morgen Vormittag
im Bayerischen Wald sorgt das für
Probleme viele Straßen sind blockiert
andere kaum noch zu erkennen zum Schnee
kommen Sturmböen hinzu in den
Skigebieten wächst die Lawinengefahr
aber zum Sport zu den beiden
Achtelfinals der DFB-Pokal gestern Abend
Norbert die Bayern weiter Leipzig auf RB
hat ja gerade echt ein Superlauf drei zu
eins Heimsieg gegen viel zu harmlose
Hoffenheimer das ist das 17 Pflichtspiel
in Folge ohne Niederlage in der
Bundesliga top im Pokal im Viertelfinale
ja und Timo Werner trifft auch wieder
der verföhnte den Torjäger für einen
harten Abend denn er war viel Pech im
Spiel Berufe und so einige vertane
Chancen der 26-Jährige noch nicht wieder
der alte der braucht Vertrauen der
braucht den der braucht das Tor jetzt
habe ich Glück gehabt heute das ist dann
irgendwann gemacht hat das Vertrauen
sollte sich aus auch dieser Sieg war nie
wirklich gefährdet schon das erste Tor
gelang E-Mail Forsberg ohne große
Gegenwehr und auch Tor zwei fiel noch
vor der Pause Konrad Leimer mit dem 2:0
für den Titelverteidiger und dann war er
plötzlich wieder da ganz der Alte Timo
Werner sicherte Leipzig in der 83 minute
mit einem 3:1 den Einzug ins
Viertelfinale
alle Tore alle Höhepunkte der
Achtelfinal zu sehen bei heute.de und
der heute App und natürlich auch der
Sieg der Bayern nach drei enttäuschenden
Unentschieden in der Liga platzte in
Mainz der Knoten die 05er chancenlos der
FCB grandios das 14:0 zeigte die
Münchner sind wieder da im
Werkzeugkasten der Bayern gewinnen
bringen die Instrumente die
Bananenflanke von Neueinkauf kann Selo
der Volltreffer von Dribbler und
Vorlagengeber musiala ein Hackentrick
als no-look Pass des ex-mainzers
Choupo-Moting und gnadenlose
Effektivität im Abschluss das waren
andere Bayern als in den letzten Wochen
entsprechend entnervt die Mainzer und
der vom Platz gestellte Trainer
bosvensson und hat er direkt gemerkt
dass wir als Sieger vom Platz gehen
wollen und diese Herangehensweise diese
Bereitschaft die brauchen wir einfach in
jedem Spiel spätestens sind knapp zwei
Wochen gegen Paris in der Champions
League wird sich zeigen wie nachhaltig
der Umschwung ist
ja und dann wird PSG ohne Stürmerstar
kill young mbappé antreten müssen denn
der hat sich eine Knie und
Oberschenkelverletzung zugezogen gestern
Abend beim Ligaspiel im Montpellier und
fällt für mindestens drei Wochen aus der
WM-Torschützenkönig hatte zuvor einen
Elfmeter spektakulär verschossen Paris
gewann noch mit 3:1
das war's vom Sport danke schön
und wenn wir eben schon berichtet in den
Alpen kommt viel Schnee zusammen der
Deutsche Wetterdienst waren vor starkem
Schneefall Schneeverwehungen und
Sturmböen im Südosten und Süden Bayerns
Einzelheiten gleich vom Wetter von Essen
heute journal können Sie um 21:45 Uhr
sehen mit Anneke machen sie es gut
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ergiebige
Schneefälle werden an den Alpen erwartet
vor allem den Hochlagen und hier kann es
übers Wochenende gut ein Meter Neuschnee
geben auch Richtung Bayerischer Wald
stauen sich die Wolken des schneit hier
über längere Zeit ja und morgen lockerts
mal kurzfristig auf und dann kommt Regen
auf der geht dann an den Alpen erneut in
Schnee über schauen wir uns die Nacht an
im Süden also an den Alpen in den
hochladen oder von 1000 Meter ergiebige
Schneefälle auch in den Frühstunden dann
im Osten etwas Schnee es wird Rutsche
hier auf den Straßen dann verlagert sich
das Ganze ostwärts und es wird Trockner
die Temperaturen dazu singen auf -2 Grad
im Osten und sieben Grad ganz im Westen
Deutschlands morgen dann erst einmal
aufgelockert dann kommt Regen auf der
wandert weiter in den Süden und geht in
den Schnee über vorher im Süden sogar
noch etwas Sonnenschein bei höchsten
Temperaturen drei Grad im Vogtland und
10 Grad Richtung Niederrhein die
nächsten Tage weitere Schneefälle an den
Alpen durchaus ergiebig am Samstag im
Norden etwas Sonnenschein zwei bis zehn
Grad und Montag wird es ein wenig kühler
damit ein schöner Abend